- I have a lot of stuff
going on in my life like,
that I don't like, heroin like,
eliminates a lot of the emotions for me,
so I don't have to feel it.
Like my daughter being gone
is one of the big, big
problems right now for me.
And it really messed me up in the head
when they took her.
So like, that's why I use like that
because it just I don't have
to feel those feelings like.
- [Mark] Okay, Cameron.
So, I found you here on Skid Row
on the sidewalk this morning.
- Mm-hmm. Yes.
- [Mark] Where'd you sleep last night?
- Mainly out, well,
I have a friend who has an
apartment down here a bit.
Since I'm in search
for a person right now,
I'm kinda staying outside
so I don't miss him.
Can't miss any second of it
'cause he could walk by any
moment I turn around, so--
- [Mark] And where, and
you're from San Luis Obispo?
- Mm-hmm.
- [Mark] Which is central, close to--
- Yeah, the Central Coast,
that's where I was raised out there.
I was around on the east
coast for the past like,
been here for four years,
but before that I was on the east coast
for about eight years.
- [Mark] And what were
you doing back there?
- Just moving around and
working and stuff like that.
- [Mark] What kind of work have you done?
- I've done anything from retail
to working for Verizon
commercials in New York City.
Stuff like that.
Just kind of bounce around jobs.
I kind of know little bit of everything,
so that's always a plus.
- [Mark] What age did
you start doing drugs?
- [Cameron] I think I started well,
I used to smoke weed a lot like,
that started around eighth grade.
But I didn't really like dabble into like,
the harder stuff until
like, I was about 19 or 20.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- [Cameron] And then I took a break
from it for a long time,
I ended up having a kid,
and she's six now.
- [Mark] Where is she?
- [Cameron] She was taken
from me like two years ago.
CPS wrongfully took her from me.
- [Mark] The state took her away?
- [Cameron] Yeah, over some ridiculous
like, they weren't supposed to take her,
but they weren't gonna
listen to me so, you know?
But I haven't seen her in about two years.
- [Mark] Ah, that's sad.
- [Cameron] Yeah. I miss her.
But I'm figuring all that stuff out now.
I just I got carried
away with a lot of stuff
and messed up, and I know I did though,
at least I'm not in denial of it, so.
I'm working on a lot
of stuff right now, so.
- [Mark] Yeah. It's a struggle.
- [Cameron] Yeah, it is.
I got a lot of stuff going on, but.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And down here on Skid Row,
a lot of the girls are
getting into prostitution just to like--
- Yeah.
- Pay for things?
- [Cameron] Oh, there's,
there's quite a handful of them.
That's further down that way actually.
- [Mark] Yeah, you
haven't gotten with that?
- [Cameron] No, I can't
bring myself to do it.
I don't know.
I, people either think I do it
or have offered for me to do it.
I can't bring myself to do it though.
- Mm-hmm.
- It's not just for,
like, I'm watching what happens
to these other girls down
here makes me really sad.
But I mean that's their hustle, you know?
I respect them. I respect
what they do, but--
- [Mark] Yeah.
- It's not for everybody.
- [Mark] They're making,
they're making ends meet.
- Mm-hmm.
- Doing whatever they can.
- Yeah, that's true.
But me, nah, I've never, I couldn't.
I don't know.
Never really put it past myself
to try doing that for whatever.
- [Mark] Where would you like
to see yourself in five years?
- Five years?
Probably living out in the Bay Area
'cause I like it a lot up there.
- [Mark] Mm-hmm.
- Only because I do a lot of art.
And I'm in, I do tattooing,
and I do painting, so.
That's like my getaway from all this,
and the stress and stuff, so.
I think that's where I like
to see myself in five years.
And I know I can do it so,
I'm gonna try really hard.
Starting now, like,
this year get to there.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- But yeah, I'm just, it's
not a happy place down here.
- No.
- No, like--
Every time I come down here,
I'm just like this puts me
in such a bummer mood every time.
I don't want to feel these feelings,
like it's hard for me to
have to deal without that.
That is why I use it.
It just helps.
But it's something that I'm
trying to look past like,
I'm eventually I'm gonna start a program,
like I think I might look into more.
I did this month, like a couple weeks ago,
I looked into programs,
but I think I'm gonna start really like,
moving towards not just looking into them,
but like maybe like getting into one.
- [Mark] Mm-hmm.
Like, I wouldn't mind doing like,
an intensive outpatient treatment.
Just because I know I
have other shit to do,
I can't just stay indoors,
and like be there locked up to get clean.
Like I couldn't do that,
it would drive me nuts.
I'd have to be able to go do other things,
and safely and like,
it's kind of like a
willpower type of thing,
like I'd feel more accomplished
if I was able to like,
maintain me being sober
and being able to do stuff
on the outside, you know?
- [Mark] I mean, sometimes the pull
must be so strong, you just can't--
- Sometimes.
- You can't resist, right?
- Yeah, but that's when it all comes down
to whether like you know you
can really do it or you can't,
like, and obviously
I've gone clean before.
And I went without it for
like almost 12 years like.
And I did it by myself,
I didn't need help from, you know,
a patient treatment center
or, you know, a doctor.
I just did it myself, like.
You know, that first month was hell,
and like, I suffered for it but, you know,
I put myself there, like nothing ever,
like drugs that good, if
you think they're that good,
like nothing that good
is ever going to come
without a price.
And like whether it's
going through withdrawal
and like, feeling all that,
like, that's the price you have to pay
if you're gonna, you know, mess
around with stuff like that.
- [Mark] That goes for
everything, not just drugs.
- Yeah, that's everything for sure.
- [Mark] Absolutely.
- But especially for drugs like,
that the consequences are there,
you just have to know
whether you can handle it,
or not, you know?
And that's, that's how I see
it at least, I don't know,
but I know I can do it,
it's just a matter of me
just conjuring up the
strength to get out there
and just do it and stop
making excuses for myself.
Why I shouldn't do it like,
that's the only thing
I'm working on right now,
but I've come a long way,
so I'm getting a lot better.
- [Mark] Well, good luck.
- [Cameron] Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you for talking to me.
- [Cameron] You're welcome. Thank you.
Thank you for talking to me.
It actually made me feel
better this morning,
fucking standing there
getting all frustrated
with fucking all this stuff.